the david pakman show at david
pakman.com interesting news from Swedish
automaker Volvo Volvo appear appears to
believe that the internal combustion
engine that is gasoline or diesel
powered is going to be going away I
guess you could say the way of tailfins
on a 57 Chevy I actually don't know if a
57 Chevy had tailfins the way of the
dodo bird the way of the dodo bird
that's exactly right
volvo is going to start putting electric
motors on all cars starting in 2019 so
they are the first traditional automaker
to forgo the combustion engine of course
Tesla from the get-go an electric only
car and Volvo has been making cars since
1927 they are famous for safety and
station wagons I think we would say
right isn't that what although is most
known for I always have thought of Volvo
as the safest car around and if they're
going to market themselves as the safest
car and one of the most fuel-efficient
cars there's a democratic that will
definitely buy those metals although I
think over the last 10 years other cars
are rated as safe as Volvo so yeah still
that's what they're known for
so this is very interesting because a
lot of other manufacturers like Ford for
example in General Motors they've been
steadily increasing their offerings in
terms of the electric vehicles that are
available BMW Audi a lot of foreign
brands are offering electric options
within many of their model lines but
this is a sort of drawing a line in the
sand and saying we are just getting off
of the internal combustion engine and
just as interestingly I believe I read
this morning that Germany is going to
ban diesel and gasoline powered cars by
the year 2040 maybe a little bit
pre-emptive than wouldn't you say I mean
you've got so it's not now it's 24
exactly just saying we will be doing
this again you know what you're do that
right I guess so oh you actually after
Volvo announced this plan their shares
spiked up 1.4 percent Wow big gain
this is very financially appealing to
them of course and you know even if they
don't hit that 2019 mark and they delay
it till 2022 definitely a step in the
right direction yeah although I don't
know that it would get too late it might
get delayed one model year but not much
because these brands plan out the model
year so far in advance which is
basically working on 2019 now because in
2018 the probably already out into I
think in September of 27 is when the
2018 model year cars start coming out
like why and then it will so that way
people are like wow this thing's really
new it's only September but I'm already
getting a 2018 it's so new it doesn't
even exist yet it's exact happened it's
all PR did cell marketing right but yeah
they're 2019 model year cars are only
about 14 months away from starting to be
released if my math is correct so that's
interesting that is very very
interesting okay remember Pat Four Loko
I think you told me that you were all
about four loko right once they took the
caffeine out is when I've started to
drink them every now and but yeah wait
it's four loko still around they're
around they just don't have the caffeine
in them oh okay yeah so for logo used to
be alcohol and caffeine and it wasn't a
great combination because alcohol of
course a depressant caffeine is
stimulant and people drinking a lot of
it was a really really bad thing
sometimes it was called a blackout in a
can now there is something called Coco
Loco Coco Loco is snort oval jock ilat
powder marketed as a drug-free way to
get a buzz it's being produced by an
Orlando based company called legal lien
and the ingredients are cacao powder as
well as ginkgo biloba taurine and
guarana which are commonly found in
energy drinks although honestly I don't
know that those do anything I think
energy drinks mostly a caffeine that
actually and all the other stuff is just
marketing I don't know I mean after for
a while ginkgo biloba was like a brain
supplement that was meant to recreate
mental clarity and acuity or whatever
and then taurine and guarana
i guess i don't remember maybe those are
mild stimulant I'm not sure but in any
case snorty both chuckling would that
affect your decision to snort chocolate
then no I'm not going
no matter what I do it yeah yeah that's
the thing as some people wonder if this
will be a gateway drug of course because
if people get used to snorting chocolate
next thing you know they'll be making
brownies yeah oh I'm sorry or cocaine
yeah where are you destroying something
right but I see it as the other way
around because of course we have things
like O'Doul's for alcoholics people
wanting to get something similar to beer
that's not actually alcoholic right or
you have nicotine patches nicotine gum I
guess they have pouches now for people
who are used to chewing tobacco pouches
or patches pouches that you put in your
lip oh oh it's like a coffee grind time
thing and it's supposed to give you a
similar effect that dip would does it
cut into the lip like like tobacco does
and that's how it goes in yeah well I
think you just dissolves in your mouth
and that's how you get the effect from
it so I'm thinking you know maybe
someone has some sort of cocaine
addiction yeah they can get themselves
off of that without housing or not it
yeah I don't know about that I don't
know the effects are strong chocolate
cocoa does have some caffeine and
apparently the combination of the cacao
and the ginkgo and the taurine and the
guarana will last about 30 to 60 minutes
and that it is almost like a euphoric
type feeling it's see it's basically
caffeine right that's what it sounds
like is going on is mostly the caffeine
from the cacao and the best part of
chocolate isn't the caffeine too it's
the taste why would I want to snort it
you got to taste the trunk go with that
I would stick with that story that I
like that you insist on that no but you
would never snort Nakhla well I wouldn't
start anything it's crazy
yeah but it's disturbing it's just not
good it's just not good
injectable chocolate though okay a
different story I would take a chocolate
IV any day now I'm kidding you don't
even get to enjoy the experience right
maybe the caffeine a little bit but like
I said the whole point of chocolate is
to eat it yeah I've been to chocolate
factories and no eight-year-olds blew up
like a blueberry so in that sense it was
not representative of Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory deranged story and
what are like the lessons in that story
don't chew gum don't be annoying you
know couldn't they have picked better
morals to go after and what is the the
gum chewing
the girl go up no she was the one that
blew up yeah oh okay
yeah okay yeah I've not seen that movie
for a while okay good movie though
how the hell of them alone okay let's
talk a little bit about cotton swabs do
you know people Pat who stick cotton
swabs known sometimes by the brand name
q-tip in their ear canal I used to be
one myself okay but you stopped yeah
it's really not a good idea I know a lot
of people that put q-tips in their ears
to try to move earwax
and there are now updated clinical
guidelines from the Otolaryngology head
and neck surgery Journal and it says
really don't do it it's really really
bad never put anything smaller than your
elbow in your ear you should not put
anything smaller than your elbow
how could you do something larger than
your elbow and your that's the exact
point which just you really shouldn't be
putting stuff in your ear and even a
fingertip could do damage and it is it
you can cause all sorts of problems you
impact the wax if that's what you're
trying to solve and it makes it even
worse you can damage the eardrum you can
cause significant pain you can cause
hearing issues etc etc and so many
people love doing this they feel like
it's just a great thing no it's a
terrible thing especially because when
you think about your ear canal and your
eardrum I mean it's a one-way street
right now like you're pushing the wax
all the way into your head or something
absolutely going to tact up against your
eardrum and if you have se blocked ears
from the wax or whatever you're making
that problem ten times work you've got
to let nature do its job the ear wax is
there specifically to basically catch
imbed dot dust or dirt or whatever and
it will eventually flush itself out
sometimes it doesn't happen some people
have accelerated ear wax deduction and
that's me and that go great well listen
we're learning a lot about past medical
history here but what are you doing that
case Pat take it away oh you don't know
I know I know but I don't know if it's
the answer that you're going to get well
what do you do okay so I used to have
this problem which was exacerbated by me
using the q-tips sure and I would go to
the doctor and they would take this
type thing and crush water and hydrogen
peroxide into my ear yeah that didn't
work so well for me and I kept having to
make these doctor's visits were a little
bit expensive so I had to find another
solution my solution now every few
months I use a Water Pik okay one of
those things that you're supposed to use
to floss your teeth with right and I put
warm water and hydrogen peroxide in it
and it just Jets out water and flushes
the whole thing out it's fantastic okay
great have you asked your doctor if
that's okay to do that yeah I mean they
did it on me first and I just bought the
Water Pik because I was sick of paying
like the co-pays to the doctor then yeah
but I just don't know if the water pick
is the same thing as a syringe but
anyway long story short yes you can buy
a water a small water I don't even know
what it's called it's like a bubble it
will have these ear back things like I
do which don't even involve water but I
haven't you haven't I haven't had to
move on to that because the Water Pik
works so effectively for me I'm just not
sure if the ear vac is approved and and
now but anyway yes you basically use
water there's drops that will you know
deal with it but don't put q-tips in
your ears I actually have a friend who's
an emergency room doctor and he said
that it's pretty common that people show
up because they've had some issue with
q-tips in their ears if you look at the
labeling on q-tips they say very
specifically don't apply directly in the
ear canal I mean you can use it like
around your ears I guess and the little
crevices yeah what have you but not in
the ear canal now what you definitely
don't want to do is something called ear
candling have you heard about this oh
yeah yes you're a candidate one of the
solutions Fraser won a total scam and we
actually were approached by an ear
candling company that wanted us to
advertise their products and the idea is
you basically put a this is a rough
explanation you put a lit candle right
up to your ear and the idea is that the
flame on one side of the candle will
draw out toxins from inside your ear
okay and you take the candle out of your
ear and many times people see oh the
bottom has sort of changed color so
those must be the toxins coming out of
my ear it turns out that that happens
anyway because of the vacuum that is
sort of caused by the candle even if you
were just to go outside in
a city yo they'll pick up a stuff see I
didn't think it had anything to do with
toxins maybe that you're just melting
the earwax and then it's not a sticky
and just falls right out my
understanding is it's not bad is that
it's pulling out the stuff that's in
your ear who even knows I focused at the
point I don't understand how companies
are successful with this because you can
just go to the store and buy a candle
for a dollar you know yeah but it's not
the right type of candle it doesn't come
with the right packaging you've not paid
enough for it which is a big thing you
buy the you buy the candle and it
doesn't say this is meant to remove your
wax that's exactly right that's exactly
right
don't do it people often will get burns
inside the ear from wax they'll drift
sin I mean just it's the way where's
problem what are you doing looking like
your hearing or your site you want to be
extra careful with absolutely absolutely
all right so anyway hopefully everybody
will have a good weekend now that we've
talked about this of not using q-tips or
candles to deal with your ears and next
week it is a full week patch I think
right yes we're here for the full week I
know I am okay I'll figure out whether I
became better cat we'll be here all
these messages the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]